early morning on saturday and a missile
slams into a residential building in the
ukrainian capital
the moment captured from inside the
building on a security camera
a gaping hole left in the building's
side as russian forces attacked kiev
from the north east and south
emergency workers arrived to rescue
those inside
uh we managed to escape we were in the
kitchen we were lucky it was a direct
hit into the living room my wife and
elder child broke their legs the younger
child was taken somewhere by the
rescuers i'm looking for him now
the attack followed fierce fighting in
the capital overnight people watched
from their homes as battles raged on the
streets outside
people have been urged to take shelter
though it's not clear where and the city
is safe
russia has said it's only targeting
military infrastructure but ukrainian
officials are accusing moscow if hitting
civilian areas
a convoy of russian trucks has been seen
rolling into ukraine but the president
vladimir zelensky is said to have
refused an american offer to evacuate
insisting he will stay and fight
good morning ukrainians there has been a
lot of fake information online saying
that i'm calling on our army to lay down
arms and to evacuate
listen i am here we will not lay down
any weapons we will defend our state
because our weapon is our truth and the
truth is that this is our land our
country and our children and we will
defend all of that that's all i wanted
to tell you
a man in southern ukraine has been
filmed standing in front of the russian
military
on friday president zielinski asked
europeans with combat experience to take
up arms to defend his country accusing
the west of being too slow to help
as the fighting continues families
shelter in hotels or metro stations
trying to rest whenever they can
while tens of thousands of others are
crossing into neighboring countries in
search of safety
but more russian troops are heading
towards ukraine
and there are warnings including from
french president emmanuel macron of a
long war ahead alexi o'brien al jazeera